what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness news now i
know it's actually been a pretty long
time since we've gotten any news about
doctor strange 2 but today for those
fans who are really excited for this
movie we have some great news for you
and i know a lot of people of course are
excited for spider-man no way home let's
not forget that the ending and the
events of spider-man no way home are
going to tie directly into multiverse of
madness in fact that ending that we see
in the trailer where doctor strange says
they're coming through and i can't stop
them what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
that looks to be pretty much when the
multiverse breaks into madness but we'll
know soon enough what the actual story
plot is going to be or at least a little
bit of a tease of it because the teaser
trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness should be coming
pretty soon so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news
especially when that trailer is going to
be coming out but let's talk about right
now what we've heard we've heard a
little bit about the trailer and thanks
to some leaks it looks like we could
have a villain reveal with so much
happening in one movie the repercussions
of spider-man no way home the events of
one division tying into multiverse of
madness the possibility of villains
coming from other universes there's just
so much that could be going on it's nice
to get a look at who a potential main
villain could be but first let's talk
about that teaser trailer because i know
a lot of people are wondering when
exactly is this coming according to a
report from the account big screen leaks
who is a very reliable source and a
friend of the channels they stated the
other day just got word that the first
trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is done and ready
to go hoping to get some details soon
now of course with the hype of
spider-man no way home we sometimes lose
sight of the other huge marvel movies
that are coming and like i mentioned and
like everybody should know by now
spider-man no way home directly connects
to doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness just like how spider-man knowing
home is picking up right where far from
home left off pretty much doctor strange
is gonna pick up right where no way home
is gonna leave off the fact that the
trailer is done and we should be getting
it soon makes perfect sense in fact more
often than not recently marvel studios
trailers overlap with films releasing in
the theaters just like she was in
theaters but we were getting trailers
for the eternals and since doctor
strange is going to play such a huge
role in spider-man no way home
spider-man no way home is going to most
likely tease upcoming events in
multiverse of madness the fact that they
would release the trailer soon after noe
home releases just makes sense but i am
definitely betting that we are getting
it after the release of spiderman no way
home i'm guessing probably sometime in
january maybe a little bit later since
there were some delays and it got pushed
back but if it's done and ready to go
that means they're probably planning on
putting it out soon and from there we'll
learn a little bit more about the film
and what to expect although it will just
be a teaser but like i mentioned we have
learned at least one of the villains
that is most likely going to be in
multiverse of madness thanks to a lego
leak a disclaimer we've had some lego
leaks be true in the past and not true
in the past but rumor has it right now
that this leak is real one of the
villains for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to be
gargantos now this is coming from
gargantos being on the box of a lego set
and this is rather interesting news
because at first we thought that
schumachorth was going to be one of the
main villains but perhaps somebody
simply saw tentacles and thought that
gargantos was actually shumagorth but
according to the rumors and reports it
is indeed gargantos and this is actually
rather interesting because gargantos is
associated with namor namor the
submariner who is reported and rumored
to be making his mcu debut in black
panther 2 wakanda forever now a lot of
people are rumored to be making cameos
in multiverse of madness and perhaps
namor isn't going to make his debut in
black panther 2 but perhaps he'll make
his debut in multiverse of madness if
you don't know who gargantos is don't
worry not a lot of people do even if
you're pretty familiar with the comics
he's only mentioned about two times
first in 1969's the sub mariner number
13 and then again 20 years later in
1989's x factor annual number four
gargantos is a huge underwater sea
creature that dwells on the continent of
lumuria in gargantus's first appearance
the lumerian tyrant naga sought to best
name more of atlantis so he did this by
sending his monstrous champion gargantos
after namor however that didn't really
work namor defeated gargantos and
dethroned naga we then see gargantos
again related to lumeria when their
lumerian villain goer kidnapped jean
grey and to my knowledge those are the
only times we see gargantos but it is
worth noting that both times that we see
gargantuas the x-men are involved and
there are some pretty heavy rumors and i
have heard some things about the x-men
appearing in multiverse madness you've
probably caught a few videos i've done
on this and if half the things i've
heard are true then things are about to
get really really exciting but if you
think about it doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is a movie where
literally anything could happen you
could introduce the x-men the fantastic
four you could introduce namor you could
introduce anyone and you could find a
way for it to make sense you could keep
toby maguire spider-man and have him in
doctor strange too same thing with
andrew garfield spider-man you could
have the scarlet witch be a villain an
actual villain she could be possessed by
a demon god literally anything is
possible with this movie when you
combine masters of the mystic arts magic
witchcraft and then the actual
multiverse on top of that but this
actually kind of complicates things and
makes things rather interesting because
even if gargantos is in the movie he may
not exactly be from our universe keep in
mind multiverse of madness is going to
introduce america chavez and her
superpowers are literally the ability to
create star portals into other
dimensions she has interdimensional
travel and from what we've heard so far
she actually is not going to originally
be from our universe but will come into
our universe via her powers this is
where apparently doctor strange and wong
are going to run into her after all it
is kind of their job to kind of protect
their own reality like doctor strange
told tony stark in avengers infinity war
so other dimensional beans coming into
the main mcu timeline is kind of a
problem and kind of the job for the
masters of the mystic arts and from what
we've heard so far when america chavez
gets to our world she says that she was
fighting some giant monster this could
possibly be gargantos now as far as why
should we be fighting gargantuas in her
world who knows we don't really know
much about the movie at this point in
time there are a lot of rumors going
around and anything is really possible
in this movie like i said but the good
thing is we are going to be getting a
teaser trailer for the movie relatively
soon like i said definitely after
spider-man no way home but hopefully not
too far after that but i want to know
from you all in a movie where anything
is possible they could literally bring
in the old x-men from the fox universe
into the mcu in this movie what would
you like to see happen because literally
anything could happen even if for just a
split second while they're traveling
through universes it could still happen
so let me know what you'd like to see in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and if you want to stay
up to date on all marvel news be sure to
hit that subscribe button and hit the
notification bell as well so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you